I am very excited to introduce you to Simone.
Yatch.
Her name's spelled differently,
but that's how you pronounce it.
A Simone is Sweden born and a descendant of Erickson founder Lars Magnus
Ericsson.
Oh,
cool.
Is that someone describes herself as the queen of shitty robots,
breaker of transistors,
mistress of malfunction,
mother.
I'm terrible interventions.
However,
I really prefer inventor tainer coined by Rediker supposedly.
Uh,
she explored engineering physics in college before finding her true calling on
youtube.
I'm not sure why,
but her family calls her pim.
Uh,
you can check out someones terribly brilliant creations on her youtube channel
Googlers.
Please welcome Simone to Google.
[inaudible]
yeah,
I think that this is the first time that I've heard that youtube is my true
calling.
All it is.
At least for now,
it's legitimate,
but I'm just like,
have I said that
I know?
Yeah,
sure.
Yeah.
Youtube is my true calling the youtube team.
Clapping while,
uh,
crimes,
all emotional.
So for four before talking about shitty robots,
I'm completely jealous about your recent vomit comet trip that you a clue it on
youtube channel is party verace.
Dot Training.
Uh,
describe how it works and what I'm most interested in is what it's like that
moment you become weightless.
So a little bit of background story.
I took a month long break from shimmy robots because I really want to go to
space.
I'm a wonder a hundred 100% serious about it.
And uh,
I actually got funding from Google to do it from Google's making and science
team.
So thanks for that.
But I got to go on the vomit comet zero g flight on the,
on the last episode.
So basically it's this airplane,
the Dus parabolas so it goes up and down really fast so you get to experience
what it's like to be weightless.
And it was,
I was,
so first of all I had to pee really badly,
which like took cause you're like both worried about vomiting and about peeing
at the same time.
So it was a lot of body fluids to keep on track.
You know,
I feel like 25% of my brain power went to that.
But it was the craziest feeling cause you're,
you're laying down on the floor and first you experienced an increased amount of
g forces because you're accelerating and then you just get lighter and lighter
and it feels exactly as if you pictured like meditating,
you'd start levitating cause you just like very slowly float up.
And it actually made me really sad because while it felt like the wildest and
weirdest thing I'd ever experienced,
it also felt so natural.
Cause I was like,
yeah,
of course this is something that humans do.
And I think like,
I mean everybody,
every human being dreams about flying and what it's like to be flying.
And it was like,
yeah,
this is,
this is what I'm made for.
And then you get back to gravity and you were like,
no,
I'm like bound to this big like dirt ball gravity.
Any gravity is the biggest Downer on planet earth.
The Yard I've used such as before.
Yeah,
we got to work on no growth and no gravity team.
It's gotta be one on Google somewhere.
Uh,
so you talked your way into a job as a professional maker for a startup in the
bay area.
How hard was it to Waco walk away from basically a real job and find your way to
make a living on your own where you constantly convincing your friends and
family that it wasn't a huge mistake.
So who was it that was not the way it happened?
It was more because I did have a great job.
So I started learning.
I didn't,
I dropped out of college after a year,
so I started studying physics,
but I dropped out because I just felt it was a little bit too dry.
And um,
I really wanted to learn about electronics because I saw all these like
different DIY projects that people were building and I thought that they were
super cool and I remember being like,
should I go back to school for it or should I try and learn by my own?
And what I decided on was like,
no,
I should try and get a job in the field so I can get paid to learn about it.
So I got a job at,
as a maker in residence at a company that makes a microcontroller or an Arduino
board called the light blue bean and they were here in the bay area and it was
really great.
Like the job was super fun,
but I just wasn't very enthusiastic about it.
And I decided to quit because I realized that I'd like,
I've tried a lot of different things,
I've had a lot of different jobs and it was like,
it's like trying on different pairs of pants and you're like,
ah,
these pants kind of work.
But they are like crawling up my buddle it a bit or these ones are a little bit
too sure.
And you're just like trying on all these different jobs and work,
uh,
to see what fits you.
And that was like,
yeah,
it's like right,
I love what I'm doing,
but it's like the setting of it doesn't really work.
So it was actually that I quit my job not knowing what I was going to do and I
decided to move back to Sweden and to like cut back on all of my costs.
So I moved back with my mom.
I lived on like half a gigabyte of data every month,
you know?
Yeah,
it was rough.
But all of those just,
and I try to work as little as I had just to make a living just so I could free
up a lot of time spending to spend on whatever I wanted and to pursue,
like what I was enthusiastic about and from that platform or from that time that
I freed up was where I started building these shitty robots.
So it wasn't,
I mean,
yeah,
maybe it was the way you said it,
but my parents have always been very supportive and were like,
yeah,
do whatever you want.
It'll be fine.
Um,
I think it's more been my brother and my brother was like,
I remember him at some point being like,
Simone,
he calls me the walking life crisis.
He's like,
Simone,
if you're ever going to do something great,
you have to like settle down on like what you're going to do or like choose a
field and like go for it and spend more than a year on it.
Um,
but I think it was,
yeah,
actually it wasn't that hard of a decision.
It would have been harder to stay.
Yeah.
So you mentioned you don't have an engineering degree,
but you've got creative experiment and build stuff,
which sounds like engineering to me and probably a lot of people in the room.
Uh,
a maker for sure.
Do you see yourself in any way as a role model and stereotype buster for girls
interested in
tech?
No,
I struggle with that one.
Uh,
in part I often get the question if I see myself as a role model for girls and
in some way like what I hear is,
and think,
I think there's like something inherently wrong with it because it's like people
have this perspective that as a woman you can only be a role model for girls.
And people are always like,
you're such a great role model for girls.
And I think actually it's just as important for men to have female role models
as for girls to have female role models.
So,
I mean,
and I mean that's aside from me probably not being a great role model in many
ways,
but I'm like telling myself that people can cherry pick the good parts and
you're like exclude the bad parts.
Um,
but I mean I hope,
I mean to me it was also,
I mean it was,
it was really important to see other,
it does get like stronger when you see another woman or somebody and you can
identify a little bit more with doing the thing that you want to do.
And it wasn't until I saw a woman giving a talk on hardware hacking that I was
like,
oh boy,
like if she can do it,
I can do it too.
Because you realize,
because I was always interested in building things and making things,
but I never saw myself as somebody being interested in technology and
electronics.
And I think that's just like,
because you've been brought up with the stereotype of like,
oh,
this is the type of person that wouldn't be interested in it.
And,
uh,
it takes seeing somebody who you can identify yourself with to be like,
wait,
this,
like this is all just bullshit.
It doesn't make sense.
Yeah.
So what's the first,
a lot of people go down an engineering or make her path.
They've taken something apart that they probably weren't supposed to or they
built something.
So what's the first thing you took apart?
What's the first thing you built?
Do you remember?
I just about to take this mic apart.
Um,
I,
the first thing I remember and it kind of cool project,
we had this like old,
um,
what's it called in English like this,
uh,
like,
well,
you know,
when you're getting television,
television,
satellite dish,
like the big like parabola.
They were like the big thing you had on your house,
those white.
Yeah.
So we had one of those in that we were going to throw away and I was like,
I looks cool.
And I turned it into a chair when I was like nine.
So I like built up,
it was the most uncomfortable chair.
You kind of like you can,
you kind of like slid out of it?
Cause it's like very like just around.
So I bought like a little podium undergrad.
Um,
I think that was the first,
but I did also,
I remember I attempted to build a robot when I was like seven or eight and I had
this grand idea of what this robot would be,
but all I got to wise,
I got a block of wood and I drilled a hole through the wood and I put a stick
through the hall and it was a robot because of your wiggled one end of the
stick,
the other end would move too.
And I was like,
yeah,
I just felt a robot.
It wasn't that,
what are we talking about?
Like whatever.
So you know,
um,
yeah.
What's been the response been to toy hauler,
toy hackers,
this partnership,
you have a golden locks.
And how'd that come about?
Um,
so I,
to me it's like a constant,
a lot of people think that I'm doing like kids content because like if you just
see the,
the,
the little videos of,
of,
of my projects,
it looks like,
I mean it looks like it's something for kids,
but then
I'm just not very kid friendly and my sense of humor.
So I've been trying and I like constantly hub.
I'm surrounded by disappointed parents all the time cause they're like,
I just really want to be able to show this to my son,
but I can't cause you keep dropping the f bomb and the bomb and the bomb and the
all the bombs.
No,
I did not say that.
Oh my God.
Well pretty much,
yeah.
Pretty much.
Yeah.
No.
Um,
but yeah,
so I'm trying to find ways in which I can like,
okay.
Give kids good content to watch her watch my videos.
So I've been,
I've been collaborating with Goldieblox,
which is this toy company that has like a female heroine.
This is really cool inventor.
And we did a Tory hacker series and they're also going to roll out,
um,
censored versions of my videos.
So like kid friendly versions.
So yeah,
which I'm really excited about.
So there would be kid friendly versions,
uh,
living on their channel so I can just be like,
hey,
parents,
don't be upset with me.
I've done,
I've done my part of it.
Um,
but yeah,
no,
it's,
it's actually really nice because as much as like my content isn't that kid
friendly,
it's when you have like 10 year olds,
right.
You and be like,
Hey,
I built this thing inspired by this thing.
You Dad that like,
you're like,
I'm so good.
I just see it.
So you just get emotional from feeling so great about yourself.
So,
um,
you kind of mentioned this with your brother.
I'm not sure how you could plan for the success you've found online is having a
master pan plan for your life or even the weekend coming up.
Totally overrated.
I mean,
it really depends.
So when I was younger,
I always had like five year plans.
I was like the Russian economy.
Like,
this is what I'm going to do in the next five years.
And then it never happens.
Um,
so now I'm more,
I mean I think it's like I tried to not have a plan so I've been doing this for
one and a half years.
It's been happening in pretty quickly.
It was one and a half years ago since I published my first shitty robot.
And I realized that like when you kind of get dragged into to to this like high
paced thing,
it's like hard because everybody wants you to have a plan and I'm trying to,
cause it really started with something that I did just because I was
enthusiastic about it and I'm trying not to have a plan because I feel that as
soon as I have that and I'm like,
I'm going to do this,
this is like the true trajectory.
I feel like I'm going to kill my enthusiasm and that's just going to kill it
itself.
But I do,
it's,
I mean I have longterm goals like going into space and I also want to go into
deep sea submarine that's covering like the whole spectrum.
Yeah.
That's coming.
So it's like really low and really high and um,
yeah,
but I try not to like limit myself to it,
but I mean it all depends on what you,
I mean I,
I,
I freak out whenever I feel that I'm like coroner it into something.
So I think if I were like,
this is what I'm going to do and I'm going to walk myself into it.
I mean I've been really like trying to not lock myself into any contracts or
anything like that because I just want to keep on reminding myself that like if
I wake up tomorrow being like,
I never want to put out another video,
that's okay.
I think you should have youtube channels,
involuntary space travel where you just take random people and you put them up
in their face and see what happens.
Anyway.
All right.
So like I'm just popped into my head.
Uh,
so like many youtube creators is a blur between your personal life and your,
your youtube persona.
I'm thinking in particular of your hilarious battle with the septic system of
your houseboat,
which is so funny.
You know,
I've seen it if you want to see true.
Um,
how do you protect your privacy?
Are you totally given up?
I think it's,
I mean,
for one it's like
I just try to remind people that like in real life,
as much as I feel,
I mean I'm not like acting like somebody else on my youtube channel,
but you're like a watered down version of the youtube because like when you're,
when you're doing a video,
you're basically like,
you have like 45 minutes of footage and you like,
you just like cut it out and like Polish like this little diamond and turn it
into like a four minute video.
So in real life you're just like more boring version of that,
you know?
Um,
but I think it's,
I mean it's hard cause it's like,
it's definitely a different type of,
my mom's a TV host and back in Sweden where I'm from and she's been a TV host
for last 20 years and it's like a very different type of celebrity,
uh,
because people,
it's like when you,
when you're on the Internet,
people know you more personally.
And in a more informal setting and not,
they don't really know like the professional you.
Um,
so definitely makes it,
I mean it's,
it's definitely a much more blurred,
but I try to,
I mean,
I,
okay.
I'm also like an information,
just open book.
Like I can't,
I don't have any secrets.
I share everything.
Like it's,
it's compulsive.
Like I'm a compulsive overshare in many ways.
So I thought and prayed and I'm,
I'm fine with like stories about me making a fool out of myself and sharing
that.
But I am like really reluctant to show footage of my family or the people around
me cause I can,
like,
I can take people being mean to me in the comments,
but if I would have like my sister in a video and they'd be mean to her,
I just like stab my computer screen,
I think.
Yeah.
So,
uh,
I was interviewing a friend of yours utuber Diana cower and,
and she said she has to block a words like kitchen and ears from comments.
Don't why?
It's basically people are evil.
Um,
yeah,
she does get a lot of Collins without her ears.
Oh,
weird.
It's fair.
I don't think I've ever gotten in Commons about my uterus.
And I'm like,
are they feeling boring areas?
So how do you deal with trolls or have you been blessfully not even to deal with
that?
So I've only put up one filter on my channel and I made the,
the,
the mistake of telling people that I put out a filter.
So I've seen so many creative spellings of Dildo.
Um,
but I think that's,
yeah,
that's probably the only one.
I mean it is like as I just hit half a million subscribers yesterday.
Yay.
Uh,
number happened to lead in the room anywhere maybe?
No.
Yeah,
there you go.
Yeah.
Oh,
thank you.
that's great.
Um,
cool.
I,
yeah.
Um,
so as,
I mean,
I definitely notice it like as you grow a,
people get progressively meaner and meaner cause like when it's small,
it's just the people who sought you out and he really like it.
But as you grow,
there's like people who didn't really often and they get very upset about you
showing up in their feed or like when the worst is like one a video trends on
youtube.
So I locked myself in my bathroom for 48 hours and that one trended on Youtube.
And when it does that,
it like,
it's like you just like have like this little,
what do you call,
like when you're fishing and you just open up in that and you just get all the
weird sea creatures,
like you get all of it,
all of it.
Um,
but I have actually,
I'm like scared to talk about it cause I don't want to jinx it.
But I've been weirdly spared from a lot of hate.
Um,
and especially being a woman on the Internet,
which tends to be worse.
And like,
I mean,
it's definitely different on different youtube channels.
Like on the test and youtube channel,
I worked for another youtube channel called test at,
it's like refer or just more like focus on my appearance and my sexual
preferences,
very relevant to the videos.
Um,
but on my youtube channel is actually been really nice.
And,
um,
I didn't really know what I've done or haven't done to deserve that.
But it's,
yeah,
it's,
it's been surprisingly nice.
So maybe you,
the,
on the,
on the positive side,
you mentioned that a 10 year old might say,
Hey,
I was inspired to build something.
So what's the sweetest,
most memorable thing a fan has done that makes everything you're doing worth it?
I mean,
it's,
it's a lot I think.
Um,
I mean now I'm starting to get like messages from people who have gotten into
engineering school,
um,
because because they sought it out after like seeing my videos,
which feels really weird because you're like,
I am can,
you can like put people on a different life trajectory so that,
that feels really like an honor to be able to do that.
But I think it was like I'm a sucker for getting packages and people send me
such nice things and projects that they built a actually had a people who
fabricated or a guy named Stuart who fabricated this whole robot arm,
uh,
for me.
And he like made it out of like custom aluminum.
Everything was really polished.
He like put like in video footage of him building it.
I mean it was,
must have been like kicking him a week to make it and just the fact that
somebody would spend that much time just to make you happy is,
is pretty wild.
Yeah.
Well someone in the eye as mentioned pantry on,
so you ran into a bit of sponsored trouble that you talked about and what's been
your experience with crowdsourcing?
Financial support is another vehicle.
What would you have offered for other creators that want to go that path?
So if you don't know,
there is a platform called Patrion and there,
there are multiple platforms I'm on Patrion but where people can give monthly
donations to different independent creators.
And I think it's a really,
it's such a beautiful thing because it's really a democratization.
Did I pronounce that right?
Yeah.
Okay.
Um,
of,
of content creation because otherwise,
I mean it just makes it a lot.
You,
there's something really sad I find about being an internet person because what
it's all about is like increasing your value as a billboard for brands.
So you're,
and you kind of saw your,
your audience's attention and the trust that they have for you.
And it's just something about that it feels really dirty.
So having alternatives like Patrion is really beautiful and people can go and
support you directly.
It's also really scary.
Like I was pretty reluctant to start a patrion because otherwise I can just be
like,
I don't,
I don't owe people anything.
I feel like,
I mean I don't,
I don't,
I don't know anything,
but I flew him for my patrion supporters.
I really feel that I'm owing them a lot and it's,
it's like a scary thing and many,
cause I'm just like,
the worst thing would be if people were disappointed in you because it'd be like
having 2000 parents who were just like,
Simone,
we just expected more of you.
That's right.
Um,
so I think there's some really cool stuff in our world right now that if you go
back in time would blow people away.
And I think one of those is a three d printer.
So if you could go back in time when the three d printer,
what would,
what's a crazy thing you would build?
Or maybe what have you built with a three d printer that you think would blow
people away?
I actually may loose thing.
This might be my best contribution to the world.
Do you guys know Neti pots?
No.
50%.
Yeah.
Can't believe I'm talking about this.
Neti pots.
It's like this weird,
my dad is like an old hippie Yogi,
Dan.
And he always had these many pods.
So basic like it's like with a little pot and you like pour water through your
nose when you have a cold.
It's really nasty,
but it's very effective.
Yeah.
If you're sick.
So I did.
I was,
I had a call then I was like,
I don't have a Neti pot.
What do I do?
I have a three d printer,
so I,
I may like a little nutty Putin awful that goes on just like a regular bottle.
It's the best thing I've ever made.
Like I'm like,
it's a legit thing and that's what I bring to people in Medieval Times.
And they'd be like,
we have no bottles.
I'm like,
Oh shit.
The hell of the plank.
95,
75.
Um,
so what is your worst robot failure that was so bad that it didn't even rate
being shitty?
That's tricky.
I mean,
I feel like it's,
it's,
it's tricky to say like when people ask me like what my shittiest invention is,
it's like,
are my most useless.
It's hard because I've skewed to me,
I'd like skewed what shitty means because to me is shitty robot would be that
worked really well or that worked poorly,
but did it in a very uninteresting way.
I mean,
the shittiest robot is the one that doesn't start,
but that's like,
I mean,
yeah.
Um,
I think my shittiest invention,
I think,
I mean,
I,
I passed on a lot of ideas,
so I start building them and then I'm just like,
no,
this isn't going to,
it happens fairly rarely.
But,
um,
I think I've started building stuff and then I'm like,
I can't,
I can't go through with us.
What kind of causes that you started and you stop,
which we do all the time here.
You know,
things you just decided it's not going to work
either.
That it's too complicated.
I can't do it in a timeframe that's worth doing it.
Um,
but I think,
or just that I don't think it's fun or relevant anymore,
but I think probably the shittiest machine I've ever made,
it's a pun,
is a the ass wiping robot probably pretty shitty.
Yeah.
We actually filmed another video on it for tested and I don't think we've
published it.
I don't think we're going to publish it because I didn't,
a lot of people were disappointed that I didn't.
So I did a by wiping real loud,
it's like a toilet paper roll on a drill.
And it just like,
and people were so upset in the comments,
they're like,
Simone,
you couldn't even have like put some Nutella.
They're like this is not believable.
And we like foam to tested video.
We're like,
okay,
we need to like put something that looks like poop in there.
And then like halfway through when you're holding this like mannequin,
man,
I don't want this to be on the Internet.
How do we end up here?
Yeah.
And I think America is the only thing that would take that robot cause that
looked like it could be a torture.
Yeah.
There's no way I'm putting my own bud in their new yeah.
And that's,
I mean I've had that idea for a long time,
but I didn't know how to do it cause I was like I can't do it with anyone's
real.
But,
and I was like,
I'll just buy a setting mannequin.
Yeah.
I had a chance to interview Adam Savage several years ago and was struck by how
down to earth he is.
I like to call them an accidental celebrity.
I really enjoyed your back and forth with Adam on the show tested that you
mentioned trying to work out the popcorn machine.
Uh,
walk me through creating that video,
especially the feeling you had when Adam's vacuum form hands that he created as
part of this project in gear arrived and you had to turn it into a robot.
I will feel like,
oh,
this is from Adam Savage.
ICON pressure.
Yeah.
Uh,
it was,
it was really intimidating because he's like,
I have no idea what I'm doing and he really knows what he's doing even though he
wouldn't say so.
I think,
um,
so we started working together about a year ago now,
a little bit more.
And the other first project that we bought was a popcorn helmet.
So it was like beer helmet,
but instead it was two popcorn containers and two hands.
So you don't have to use your own hands.
Um,
and yeah,
we,
we collaborated on it and he did like the hand mechanism and I got the package.
I remember the first thing I did,
I have told him this.
First thing I did was I looked at the box and I was like,
did he like give a signature anywhere?
Like could I get his autograph from here?
Just like cut it out.
I'm like,
um,
but it was,
I mean I still like whenever you,
I mean now it's a lot chiller with tested,
but in the beginning I had the worst imposter syndrome and especially building
stuff with him.
And before having met him,
it was really scary cause I was like just sweating being like I have,
I can't,
what if I don't get it together or are they going to like fire me?
But once you get to know him,
he's like the most devoted teacher and mentor.
So whenever you like don't know how to do something,
it almost feels like it makes him happy and he's like,
Ooh,
I can like explain those things.
So it,
and that just like completely takes the edge of often my fear.
So yeah,
he's,
he's been great,
but if he'd be any,
I mean,
yeah,
I think it's all due to him just being very kind,
very kind.
Cool.
That's just what he seems like an a on the other side of the glass.
So you had a terrific segment also on Stephen Colbert show recently?
Yes.
Um,
what happened behind the scenes because you only get six minutes on television,
but you would actually,
well here if you're in product group you'll be terrified of any sort of live
demo.
It's the scariest thing you do.
You had multiple live demos that you brought with you.
What was it like leading up to that six minutes that you can't do anything but
do that six minutes and you're done?
Um,
it was a lot of death thoughts,
thoughts about that?
No,
it was,
I mean the circumstances were pretty special cause so I had,
I was just about to move to San Francisco,
so I had everything packed with me and I'd been to La for Youtube Event and then
I've been to Vancouver to pick out my us visa.
And then I went,
I did the Redeye from Vancouver to New York and I came there and I was on set
for 10 hours,
like from early in the morning cause they like switched around the schedule.
Uh,
so I had 10 hours of having slept for three hours and just being super tired and
really nervous.
So it was actually pretty,
uh,
I mean it is always like painful,
but I feel like that always,
I give a lot of talks and always before I go on stage I'm like,
why do I do this for myself?
It's,
it's always like,
I always think that this is the time when everything is going to go wrong.
Um,
but they were,
so of what I'm trying to always,
when I do stuff like that is like I'm trying,
I mean especially with somebody like Stephen Colbert,
you tried to remind yourself that this is like he's one of the best in the world
and doing what he's doing and we share the responsibility of making it fun and
interesting.
So you're like in really good hands is what I'm trying to remind you my cell
phone.
But it's really scary because I brought four machines and just making sure that
all of them,
I mean,
you know,
yeah,
it was like why have demos?
Like they never work and just making sure that all of them would work reliably
was,
was really,
I was more worried about that then like what I was going to say or do.
Um,
and yeah,
but all the machines worked and I always like,
I've thought,
because I've had times when the machine doesn't start.
I did like a backend Sweden,
I did a live kids show and like five minutes before we go on stage,
the robot arm that I used for the breakfast machine just broke down.
And it's like,
you're like,
what are you supposed to do?
And that's like your responsibility.
Um,
but I've just thought that like,
whenever it doesn't start,
I'll just be like shitty.
Right.
And then it's okay.
So,
uh,
it's sorta ties into,
you were went through Canada to,
um,
to come to the states are getting visa.
So Sweden makes these top countries to live in the world's less frequently.
So what attracts you?
The United States and specifically San Francisco.
I mean,
I,
so I lived in San Francisco two years ago when I had that maker in residence
job.
I just think it's a really fun place to live and having a kind of weird job in
San Francisco.
I don't feel weird.
And Stockholm my fear feel a little bit weird.
Uh,
but here it's like everybody's a unicorn.
And I think that was really heartwarming.
And also I just love paying a lot in rent.
It's this weird thing I get a kick out of,
you know?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
got,
ask a question about Ikea because Sweden,
so if you can go into Ikea and get a debit card paid for by someone else,
you can buy anything you want,
including the meatballs,
first of all,
what you want to do that.
And second of all,
would you,
what would you build with anything you can buy at Ikea?
I like very rarely buy stuff at Ikea,
but I have gotten away.
Yeah.
Uh,
I have gotten away with a lot of times I trick people that,
uh,
if you're a Swedish and you lose your passport,
you can go to Ikea and it works as the Swedish embassy.
You can get a new one.
Um,
but what would I build?
I mean,
I've been wanting to projects that I wanted to build and that can buy,
build out of Ikea cars is I want to have a couch so you can lay down on,
and then you have a seat belt that comes from the back and you can like plug
yourself into the couch so you're like seated down and then you can just drive
to the fridge.
Uh,
probably do that.
Yeah.
For the lazy person.
And what,
what Swedish name would you give to that?
Cause all these,
I don't know,
these Ikea Real Swedish words.
Is it just a,
it's real Swedish words.
Uh,
I'd probably call it,
um,
let,
yeah,
Let,
laziness.
Oh yeah.
Okay.
So one more question from me and then the audience gets to take over.
So,
uh,
if you could have a cameo in one of the following,
which would you choose and why?
So Star Trek,
Lord of the Rings,
Star Wars,
which are recent convert to,
or at least recent viewer moving around so much,
or Shark Nedo Lord
of the Rings,
hands down.
Or that was it.
Die Wise.
Loadings when
I was a huge Lord of the rings fan when I was younger,
I went through an elvish phase.
Yeah.
Uh,
and I had a huge crush on every Orlando Bloom.
Yeah.
So I do it just to make 14 year olds.
Simone's proud.
All right.
Laurie
is if you're going to do an episode,
a seven,
not the Hobbit,
then here you go.
Yes.
Alright.
So I'm gonna grab my computer so we can do,
uh,
some dory questions,
which is our online question answer tool.
And then Somara from the Google loose team's going to help out with Mike phones.
Oh Gosh.
Yeah.
I was a,
I mean,
I wouldn't do a cameo.
I wanted to do a voiceover or like I love to do a voiceover for adventure time.
Oh,
one of my favorite TV shows and as soon as I put it out there,
I realized that they're about to discontinue the show and they've already be
recorded.
The last episode,
it made me so sad.
Oh yeah.
All right.
So first question out here.
Okay.
Uh,
you spoke briefly about the relationship between advertisers and content
creators as it relates to the quality of the work.
And I wanted to just hear a little bit more about your thoughts about that,
uh,
how it relates to the call quality of the work that you put out as a creator.
Yeah.
And,
and how,
you know,
creatures can survive.
Well,
you know,
in this relationship and what that does.
Yeah.
I think,
I mean it's,
it's definitely,
you just need to find sponsors who are fully okay with what you're doing and who
don't.
I think it is as soon as you have companies come in and tell you what you can
and can't do creatively.
I,
I mean maybe some people are better at handling that,
but I,
cause you're such a,
like as as a youtuber specially,
I mean offer you're your own producer,
you're your own writer,
you're the on camera talent,
the camera person and having somebody be like,
oh,
you can't say that.
Um,
is,
is just really weird.
And I think also like what a lot of companies that aren't very customed to the
field,
they're working with online talent.
What they don't understand is like the audience is completely accustomed to this
person being the way that they've always been.
And as soon as you start altering that,
that's immediately going to be like,
people are like,
it's like when your,
your parents like snuck in medicine and you're drinking,
you're like slick,
something weird about this.
Like you're trying to get something down me.
So,
um,
I think it's a lot of that,
like I think the most successful companies,
I mean something like audible does or where they're just like,
yeah,
you,
you do whatever we like.
We don't,
we don't really judge what,
what you do or like,
I mean within a range.
But,
um,
yeah,
I think that's the way to do it because as soon as you get the legal team
involved,
they're like,
we can't do this.
We can't do this,
we can't do this,
you can't do this.
So I think it's just being conscientious of what companies do you choose to work
with and making sure that they are very well understanding about the type of
content you make.
Pool.
So we can take one from the dory and then we'll go back in the room,
but like put a delta on it and know what,
stop asking.
Come on.
So this is actually a Google that's watching from Google,
Boston.
Hello Google Boston.
Um,
before working here I was a ta teaching assistant for a robotics class.
Your video definitely helped motivate me to build stuff in the job,
which in turn helped me get into Google.
So thank you.
Well that's not really a question.
Oh,
that's good to hear.
Question for the room.
Hey.
Oh,
there we go.
So thanks for talking.
Um,
I just wanted to know how you find inspiration for your ideas and what to do
next.
So thanks for listening.
Um,
I find inspiration.
I mean a lot of it spurs from everyday problems I have and just being,
I mean I'm just a very ambitious,
lazy person.
I think I go through lengths to,
to help myself with the everyday problems that I have.
It's a lot that,
but I mean more recently I find like there's just so much shit going on in our
world and that I feel needs shitty robots solutions.
Like the,
I did a pussy grabs back machine,
which was this arm,
this plastic arm that went out for your crotch and it was a mouse trap and I was
like,
Dang,
puts the grass back.
And I think that like now I find a lot of inspiration,
just things that are happening in society.
But I mean this summit is also just like body maintenance,
like maintaining your body in different ways and like,
yeah,
getting,
I mean most recently I did a manicure robot to help me paint my nails and yeah.
The Shampoo robot where you learn what it feels like to have your hair pulled by
a robot.
Yeah,
the wake of machine.
I think that my
got tangled up and yeah,
it was very humiliating and painful.
Alright.
Yup.
My,
my kids and I are big fans of your channels and uh,
also Peter on supporters,
um,
have to ask,
you're in San Francisco now,
uh,
again and burning man.
Have you been,
are you going,
uh,
seemed like a natural,
I was there two years ago.
Yeah,
it was.
Oh Gosh,
I'm doing that thing.
I'm doing that thing that people who have been to burning man,
they were,
it's like you can't really describe it.
It was,
it was a no,
I really,
I liked it a lot.
It was very weird.
It was such a mind fuck cause you were like with normal Simone do this or not
like how,
um,
but also I am just like not that much of a party person.
I get very tired and I need to sleep a lot and it's a long time and it was
really,
this is like a tricky thing but I'm not,
I'm not going this year but I might go in future years.
It would be fun and I feel like I could,
I'd want to build something big.
Yeah.
Cool.
Have any of your robots turn out to be not so shitty?
Kind of too useful to be funny?
Um,
because we all love when they go wrong,
but I see him sometimes.
Uh,
I actually got,
the thing is people get very upset with me if they're not shitty enough.
So for example,
when Scott and I did the bureau by um,
one of the cakes,
it kind of,
so it was a robot,
like put down the cup and then pour it a beer and like handed me the beer.
It was one of the takes where it was like,
it was still like spraying me with beer,
but people who are like,
smell this is a shitty enough was like,
what have you because,
and they were like really disappointed in me that it worked too well.
So,
um,
but yeah,
usually,
I mean they just like most of them just really sucks.
So yeah,
they're,
they're good at it.
Liz,
almost something like you,
if you get more budget,
I hope you keep it to yourself cause you shouldn't invest,
invested,
I mean robots that would totally kill it.
So I mean,
I don't want to invest in like stronger and bigger motors.
Yeah.
Okay.
But just the scale of the shittiness would go out,
but not the cool.
Yeah,
no.
All right.
No,
but I realize I have the only,
probably one of the few jobs where the,
the,
the sentence that was really shitty,
great job actually makes sense and isn't just passive aggressive.
Yeah.
We'll take a few more questions.
So we've got one back there.
Yeah.
So Simone,
ah,
you've told about how you have done a lot of different things and I,
I guess you'll continue to do a lot of different things and it's really
inspiring,
but at the same time it's,
it must've been pretty scary.
So I'm,
my question is how did you practically go about finding out and doing the right
research to become successful?
And now all of these different things that you did because,
uh,
when you start doing something new,
you might not have all the information.
So did you just like go on Google and type in how can I be an astronaut?
I think it's,
I mean,
I'm definitely not been successful at everything I've done.
I've been pretty terrible.
I have a lot of stuff.
Like,
I mean,
I worked as an MMA reporter,
I was a pretty bad umihmmmi reporter.
Um,
so I,
but like I think the key thing too,
and I understand like it's,
it's,
it's been a huge privilege,
like having supportive parents and growing up as a middle class person in the
country like Sweden because I've had the opportunity to try out a lot of
different things.
And,
um,
I think mostly like what I realize is because I had this like feeling that I was
very duty and I had this feeling that like for it to be important,
it has to be hard.
Like it has to be a struggle and you have to be,
have to push yourself really hard.
And then like in my early twenties,
I realized like,
wait,
but I'm like a lot better at the things that I'm enthusiastic about and that I
actually like in the don't really feel like work.
So I think it was just that shift in perspective and trying to pursue the things
that I feel that I'm good at and that I really enjoy doing and that somehow feel
a little bit guilty to be spending time on to,
to just do more of that.
Because that's like,
you're,
you're obviously going to be better at that.
Yeah.
And to me it's just building things.
Don't work
over here.
Thanks.
Uh,
I'm not sure how much you'd like to predict the future,
but I am very curious to know what you think the role of robotics will be in
like theatrical performances and musical performances.
Oh,
that's interesting.
Um,
I don't,
I don't actually know it's,
it's an interesting thing cause like I'm,
I'm basically,
I mean I'm a hobbyist.
The happened to gain a following and often I get like interview questions about
like what does the future of artificial intelligence?
And I'm like,
I'm not an authority in this field,
but I think it,
I mean,
I think that definitely,
people have this urge to create everything that we have around us into comedy.
And I think that as we are more,
more surrounded by technology,
that definitely gets integrated into the arts more.
So.
I mean,
I'll do a shitty robotic show.
I might even sing a little bit
so
fair in the bay area.
I have.
Yeah.
But I'm going to miss it this year.
Maker fairs still go,
but the next time.
All right,
let's take one more good,
one more audience question right back here.
Um,
I want you to ask you if one of your creations where to gain Saint Anne's,
which one would you be most afraid off and which one were you the happiest of?
Of having them become the drone hair cutter?
That would be my nightmare
drone.
Haircutter thou would be a good way.
Yeah.
But I think probably so megabots made a,
they have these huge fighting robots and they made a chopping machine extension
for their robots.
So it's like eight foot long knives.
I feel like having that one run after me would probably be peering terrifying.
I chopped up an oven with it.
Uh,
I,
I think that one and the one I most want to have sen probably the applause
machine because if it knew by itself,
like when it needed to clap and not,
that would be great.
It'd be like the perfect audience.
Yeah,
I did swap all of you out for the applause.
You're all going to be,
yeah,
you're all going to be replaced.
So how many takes it takes for me to get it.
So usually,
I mean I've like transitioned a little bit from that,
but usually what I did start,
I did it only for the Gif and that's like the whole filming the video is that I
can get a little Gif of this project working.
And I think like the wakeup machine,
I mean I do,
I mean sometimes I do like 20 takes and the wake of machine was really,
now it's nicer because they have Scott who is sitting over there who,
who helps me and can be like,
okay that was good or that wasn't bad cause otherwise it's just me and I'm like
running back and checking that everything was in frame.
And um,
but yeah,
it does take a fair amount of takes.
I think the worst mode is actually the lipstick robot.
So it had a robot arm put lipstick on me and I think I did just like five to 10
takes on that one.
But in between each take I was like covered in lipstick and I had to like wipe
it off and like try and cover it up with more,
uh,
with more makeup.
And at the end of it I had like the worst rash in my face because I just like
had like layers and layers of lipstick and you just had to like scrape it off.
But I think that was actually the most painful one.
And yeah,
so the coverup machine to go along with the lipstick meetings,
that would start,
that would actually be useful.
It works
well.
So I was like,
this is like way off brand.
I can show this.
No.
Yeah.
But that would have been something.
It just,
again,
it sounds too useful.
So sounds to useful.
They're not a lot of people.
I mean,
yeah,
a lot of people do useless,
useful things.
I can't compete with that.
Like I can't,
but I not,
I mean it's just like,
it's all about finding a field,
the small enough so you can be at the top of it.
You have cornered,
you've cornered the useless market.
You're so smart.
It's going to find,
it's like narrow enough so you're like,
okay,
I can actually like climb to the top of this thing.
I'm useless enterprises.
Oh,
I mean there is a,
I can't say that I'm the number one.
Uh,
no,
there,
there is a few people who do stuff like that.
There's a new,
a guy who's like really doing well,
his name is William and he does,
um,
he mainly does like laser cutting stuff,
but he does like really weird stuff.
Like he did a ham,
ham and cheese sandwich than diesel.
That was like laser cut layers of just ham.
So he's just like laser cut a bunch of Buckingham and it turns into this like
vin diesel model.
Um,
I think that there's also a company,
a Canadian guy runs to use like useless duck company.
So he did,
he might have seen it.
It was like a baby feeding machine where there's like an APP connected and
there's like a little bottle that goes up to a crib and the baby's like
standing.
It's a little doll and the bottle just like punches the baby in the face and it
falls over.
Well,
I want to thank you for checking down to the Googleplex today and sharing your
stories and for everyone who turned out online and virtual in Boston.
Um,
so thank you very much.
It was great.
How many here?
Thanks for letting me come.
Thanks for showing up.
[inaudible].